Ernie good morning how are you Dan if I
were doing any better I'd be jealous of
myself
how would you sum less he stole that
from somebody use it at your leisure if
you wish
sounds like a Will Ferrell line there no
that predates Will Ferrell okay no I'm
doing I'm doing great I'm back in
Atlanta here after a UH after a long
night at the ball yard how would you sum
that up if somebody didn't see what
happened last night could you sum that
up man I wish I had the I wish I had the
word for it it was wacky it was
unpredictable it was just you know it
was one of those you know it's been such
a low-scoring tight game series and this
was a tight game too but I mean the the
Cubs scored more runs in Game five and
they had in the first four games and you
know and you had the whole thing with
Max Scherzer coming out of the pen and
you know catcher's interference the
replay on the throw back by Contreras it
was just it was crazy and you know and
and the the swing of four-to-one
Washington to eight to four Chicago and
then the Cubs hanging on it was just it
was just what we expected it was gonna
be a great series when we looked at
those and said you know what that's
gonna be the best one of a bunch and and
boy it lived up to it but the pass ball
were you Ron darling aware of exactly
what what happened and what was
reviewable and not reviewable yeah
with you know and and you look at the
rulebook with what you know and that's
the umpires discretion on you know the
backswing making contact with the
catcher but the thing is when that
happened immediately weeders went to the
went to the backstop you know so we you
know wasn't like one of these things
where he got hit flush and dropped to
his knees and was dazed and that kind of
a that kind of a deal and how the
lamar's that guy had the rulebook out
and was talking kept saying to us and
some players discretion so that was the
deal
what about the pickoff throw at first
and it's a little strange to see the
umpires waiting for New York to get back
to them to say outer safe well you know
here's my thinking on that whole on that
replay and one thing that I have an
issue with a lot of those plays where
where somebody's stealing base steal and
second are trying to take the extra base
and you and you have that play and you
hold the tag on a runner on the you know
on the chance that possibly he comes off
the bag just a hair look I think there
sometimes has to be there's there's a
place to use the super-slow-mo
you know did that ball was that ball
fair or foul home run did it go around
the pole or in front of the pole and you
get every possible look because you
can't get a close look at it sometimes I
think on a play like that last night you
can use replay but it's got to be
regular speed what should the umpire be
expected to see in that case and if you
won't run that back in regular speed and
self Jesus I mean yeah he could have
been out he could have been safe and
I'll stick with the call I I mean
sometimes what do you expect an umpire
to do they don't have this kind of
vision that slows things down to super
slow-mo you know you expect him to see
that no and so I think sometimes it's
overused and sometimes it's you know it
what you saw last night was just that
fraction of an inch in it and it was a
huge plan again wait so you think
there's certain there's certain plays
where you use super slow-mo in certain
place where you do just regular instant
replay yeah because we're where an
umpire is right there this is what he
was able to see that I think if there's
a dispute right there you say okay let's
run it okay run it back in full speed
okay could you make that call what I
mean what do you expect this umpire to
see and I think in places like that I in
calls like that when you when you come
up and it's not just last night's call
we see it all the time when you know
somebody doesn't really over slide the
bag or something like that but his thigh
comes off the bag for a second just
before his foot maintains contact with
it
and how do you expect any umpire to make
that right call well you know so-so also
sometimes I think yeah I'll call like
that sure you want to replay that look
at it full speed boom but I've had
people say well in the spirit of the
game that you shouldn't call him out I
go wait now we're in the spirit of the
game I got unwritten rules in the spirit
of the game but I know where were you
supposed to go with those when they're
unwritten rules of the game as you write
your own it's not gonna hurt and so
Ernie's gonna have let me reintroduce
you and then you can go come on Ernie
I talked you about you being the most
selfless and an announcer and then here
you are wanting to get more airtime all
right so slow down he's Ernie Johnson
three times sports Emmy winner one of
the most selfless broadcasters in the
business apparently until this
appearance Dodgers Cubs at 8:00 Eastern
you got the call in Game one all right
and as you were saying Ernie I don't
have it well the the Dodgers Cubs is
8:00 Eastern and I'm game on yes yeah
the cupboard ESS but the Congress yes
has the call Ryan Anderson will be doing
it and an Ernie will have Thursday night
opening night in the NBA yeah I'm moving
over to the NBA so I'm almost afraid to
talk now because I feel like I can
friend on some sacred ground here dad
what did you make a Michael Jordan's
quote that the NBA has 28 garbage teams
two great teams 28 garbage teams say
that he was quoted yesterday I think
he's an interview in cigar aficionado so
he's talking about super teams and how
he's against these super teams and you
have Cleveland and we have Golden State
but was it wasn't Chicago a super team
although they didn't assemble their team
the same way
Golden State did but the Bulls were a
super team when they played they were
the best team you're a basketball by far
yeah without question they were and now
I look I don't think that I I'm very
hesitant to label 28 teams garbage teams
I think that I think league-wide you've
got guys who were worth watching and I
think you have a few teams that that can
contend but I mean I think the point
he's trying to make and the point that I
would agree on is that if Golden State
trots out that same bunch every night
nobody can beat him four times but I
look today I mean I hate to I hate to
take the you know I hate to take the
drama out of the season but because but
but a lot of things can happen in the
course of a season and so we and so
we'll see but I but I mean if you if you
draw it up the way it is right now you
think there's a team out there that
beats Golden State four times no if this
were March Madness
yeah maybe everybody has a bad shooting
night and somebody gets in foul trouble
and and and they lose a game but to beat
that team four times nobody has the
personnel to do that but don't we want
the two best teams to face one another
normally whenever sure playing for a
championship
Golden State against Cleveland are the
two best teams and Cleveland didn't
assemble their team like a super team
this really is based on Kevin Durant and
Kevin Durant has said look am i the
reason why Orlando didn't make the
playoffs like I don't blame me for all
the ills everything bad with the NBA I
went to Golden State somehow Atlanta's
not any good we're gonna blame it on
Kevin Durant so I understand what he's
saying but if you say Cleveland and
Golden State play again I'm fine with
that
sure I mean that's that's the way this
this this plays out and then and again
that's there's never a guarantee that
you know and you don't wish any injury
on anybody obviously but yeah I mean
this is this is uh this is the way this
thing is played the best of these meets
the best of the west and lets you know
you know and so let's do it and see if
maybe something unpredictable can happen
but I mean on paper you look at it and
Golden State's the prohibitive favorite
in the in the NBA so is that a bad thing
I don't know I used to love watching
Tiger Woods play when he was dominating
just to see how good he could play you
know I don't I don't have a problem
watching excellence in any sport and I'm
not going to turn it off you go it's
just Golden State until you know who
plays great team basketball and and play
on both ends of the floor I don't want
to see that sure you do and and so I
don't I don't think that's a bad thing I
think sometimes you just have to
appreciate the fact that you're seeing
back in his day Michael Jordan play are
the Bulls gonna win the title this year
sure they are are you gonna turn it off
no I'm gonna watch of course I am
Dodgers Cubs 8:00 Eastern but Ernie
doesn't have that tomorrow he doesn't
have that call he's gonna be getting
ready for Tuesday night the opening
night of the NBA and their coverage
begins on TNT at 8:00 Eastern Celtics
Cavs boy that should be a friendly
affair and then it'll be the Warriors
and the Rockets and you'll try to
separate Shaq and in Berkeley Kenny
pretty much plays neutral right he
doesn't know
he sir no doesn't he doesn't stir it
does he stir it up stir it up and then
let the two big guys come in yeah but
he's not really being neutral if you're
gonna stir it up then you're you're
leading one way or the other so it's not
exactly Switzerland and so and there are
times when that's the last thing I need
I said there are times where I feel like
I've kind of got the show somewhat under
control and then and then I'll get
Shaq's antic Charles no no how do you
think about those women in San Antonio
that's his favorite place to go because
he knows Charles will go on this this
rant that he's been doing for six years
and and yeah Kenny's the same way it's
just you know Kenny would just say hey
Charles Shaq was saying and you've never
said so so yeah there there are I'm
trying to kind of keep the keep the show
afloat as best I can but I there are
certain factors working against time to
time Ernie thanks for joining us as
always I'm sorry I know that I barked at
you a little bit there I didn't mean to
it I'm sorry i overstepped my bounds I
just man I feel so bad and that might
may have thrown the rhythm of the show
off somewhat or I'm gonna survive I'm
gonna survive because that's that's what
I do I mean I know Reggie Miller never
does that too you know and reg joins us
on Tuesday by the way as we get ready
for the opening night Ernie thanks
enjoyed listening to the game thank you
wonderful weekend and always good
talking thank you that's the selfless
Ernie Johnson inside the NBA three times
sports Emmy winner had the call last
night but he doesn't have the call
Dodgers in the Cubs that'll be tomorrow
night 8:00 Eastern the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience